what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
oh my god Dan Slott you beautiful
wonderful man and you're fantastic beard
you guys know we had to cover this it's
fantastic for number one it you know
it's been a long time since we got like
a tried and true fantastic for number
one which is to say the Fantastic Four
returning I mean we got it in like the
90s when when the team sucked ah but
pretty much everybody but the x-men
sucked back in the 1990s and even the
x-men kind of sucked a little bit it was
a rough time for Marvel with the near
comic bus like it was it was pretty
rough anyway the Fantastic Four are
returning now for those of you guys who
are not familiar with Marvel Comics this
is how we know Disney got the x-men and
Fantastic Four because they came back
the original decision by Marvel Comics
if the rumors are to be believed in
various interviews and so on is that it
all basically came down to the brass at
the top of Marvel saying cancel the
Fantastic Four if Fox is not gonna give
us the rights back or they're not gonna
let us use the characters then we'll
make everyone suffer and the result was
that there was a litany of fan backlash
rightfully so because the Fantastic Four
were the original first family of Marvel
that's why they're so important they
were Marvel's will for a like first you
know real first foray into the
comic-book landscape I mean to really
wait what do you had Martin Goodman and
all those guys and it was like okay you
know let's turn the Marvel comics the
comic book side into like an actual
publishing side something that we can
really do something with and you get
Stanley Jack Kirby Steve Ditko you had
these guys who basically jumped up on
the scene and just sort of cranking out
coming book characters like hotcakes
then like the Fantastic Four was the
first real attempt and that was their
answer to the Justice League and it was
huge like like people love the Fantastic
Four because they Picard and they argued
and they fought you didn't really have
your traditional superhero dynamic that
you saw in the Justice League war it's
like hey we're all friends and we just
go do things that friends do because
we're friends and that's what we do it
wasn't like that
the Fantastic Four would argue with one
another and they would have family
squabbles and so because they were so
popular when Marvel wanted to introduce
a new character or team they threw him
in the Fantastic Four black panther
originally appeared of the Fantastic
Four the x-men crossover with a
fantastic for spider-man number one
Peter went to the Fantastic Four tried
to join the team and got turned down the
Inhumans debut to the Fantastic Four now
that's the way a lot of these things
played out and so when you look at these
different things of Fantastic Four
really kind of like built the foundation
of what became Marvel Comics and so to
see them just abruptly end over a
pissing contest was really irritating
you know for a lot of different fans and
so in seeing this return it's pretty
awesome and Dan Slott dude man little
taste of man the way Dan Slott wrote
this is amazing
I was a fan of dance lots full runner
spider-man I did recognize that it was
time to let somebody else take over the
reins if for no other reason than the
fact that dance slots writing style is
pretty distinctive and so because that I
always enjoy the whole thing but to see
Dan Slott take over the Fantastic Four I
think it's gonna be pretty awesome like
I'm pretty I'm pretty excited about it
because I just I'm anxious to see where
he goes with it now initially this kind
of picks up will it's actually pretty
interesting it picks up really with like
classic fantastic fork which is to say
Alicia masters and Wyatt Wingfoot now
when I say classic fantastic floor the
reason why I say that is because these
are just too old-school characters for
the character of Y at Wingfoot he
originally made his debut in Marvel
Comics in like Fantastic Four number 50
and then Alicia masters showed up
sixteen issues later in issue number 66
but it's one of these funny situations
because when you're talking about like
the Fantastic Four mythos these are
characters that we haven't really heard
of for a long time Alicia masters we've
definitely seen and heard from but with
regards to Wyatt Wingfoot he's really
he's kind of been missing in action for
a while now this isn't really anything
of any of any real consequence because
white Wayne foot was really nothing more
than like a cheerleader for the
Fantastic Four any bang she hoped for a
while and that was about it I mean that
was really the only thing he ever really
did so it's kind of cool when you look
at the character for what it is but it
still serves as purpose now in the
middle of all this a flare pops up and
it's like the return of the Fantastic
Four
and when I initially saw this I was like
well that's a little lackluster like
this is how the Fantastic Four comes
back in the first five pages with a
flare shot into the air like that seems
kind of lame but it's funny because the
way that Dan Slott does this is one
reason why Dan Slott writing like when
he transitions from one title to the
next is usually pretty seamless because
what he does is basically pick up on
Marvel two-in-one Y chips a tarski now
the problem with this is that Marvel
two-in-one is one arc in like three
issues in and so really the run hasn't
been fleshed out yet what I'm afraid of
is that the return of the Fantastic fork
will basically kill off interest in
Marvel two-in-one because the whole base
is behind the Marvel two-in-one story it
was it was the journey of Ben Grimm and
and Johnny Storm to find the Fantastic
Four which given the nature of this
story obviously they didn't locate them
so it's kind of like okay I mean we know
how that story ends it was like when
Marvel released all-new all-different
marvel after secret work before Secret
Wars ended and so we basically knew how
things were going to end before the
story even completely unfolded in
reality I think a lot of this
done to capitalize on will what will be
or will soon say information being
dumped saying hey look here's what we're
gonna do with the Fantastic Four and all
that kind of good stuff
or the very least build on the news and
the various rumors and so on and so
forth I'm not against it I'm excited to
see the Fantastic court return I'm just
kind of worried that it's gonna kill off
interest in model two and one but we
know that that was the whole basis
behind the story but the way the Dan
Slott plays on this is that throughout
the entire Marvel two-in-one art at
least that we've seen so far and really
ever since the events of all-new
all-different marvel which is to say the
amazing spider-man when Dan Slott was
writing it Johnny storms character was
constantly struggling with the idea that
the Fantastic Four didn't exist anymore
and is one of the funny things that that
consistently has been played on ever
since the Fantastic Four ended is that
if there is no team then Johnny Storm
has no real place and so it works
because it was really kind of a way to
focus on the nature of his character
absent the actual Fantastic Four team
and so in this moment it makes sense
that he would jump in excitement and
race off to the Baxter building
expecting to see the team there the
issue at this is that Ben Grimm knows
that's not the case and this has been
the other side of Ben that we haven't
really seen before by and large Ben
Grimm has been one of two characters and
the Fantastic Four mythos he's either
been the strong guy the big lumbering
strong guy basically the heavy hitter
for the team or he's been kind of like
their emotional backbone right like when
no one else seems to be able to go on
Ben Grimm the thing is like hey guys we
got this and then just kind of continues
pushing everybody in this in this
direction now if Marvel has focused on
him a lot individually in terms of like
story arcs had centered on him outside
of the Fantastic Four line of stories
for example Civil War so I'm taking off
to France for some reason which is kind
of weird is it when you're talking about
this whole thing Ben sort of showing
this other side in terms of how he's
being written instantly saying like well
I'm essentially just kind of giving
Johnny Hope is a little dark and a
little cynical and that's why it's kind
of crazy because when Johnny shows up to
the Baxter building he finds a couple of
Yancy's Yancy Street gang kids who are
just sitting up on the Baxter building
and shot the flare into the air and so
it's not one of these things that only
Johnny Storm noticed it was a very
exciting moment because the world wanted
to see the Fantastic Four return it's
one of those things were the way that
Dan Slott writes this is a reflection of
the Marvel Comics readers even if the
Fantastic Four haven't been selling that
well for the last thirty years which
they haven't and even if the Fantastic
Four have done a lot of things that have
basically gone under the radar which
they have if they really haven't
in a top-tier team in the eyes of sales
and storytelling for the last few
decades there's still the first family
and so even if people say like the
Fantastic Four need to come back and
they would read the first arc and never
read it again there is still kind of a
position where the Fantastic Four have
to be here because it's one of those
things where the significance of the
team in recent years hasn't been in like
Hickman and mill you know and Mark
Miller style storytelling it's been in
the fact that like Tony Stark can figure
something out so he goes to Reed
Richards Johnny Storm pops up and says
hey spider-man what's going on I mean
these are things that made the Fantastic
Four interesting because they kind of
had their life you know the Fantastic
Four were the equivalent to the guy
who's been on the job side for 40 years
so he just kind of does whatever he
wants to do and who the hell's gonna
tell him no because he's just been there
that damn long like that's what the
Fantastic Four are like and so is one of
these these cool situations because
where the the news inside this would
basically go through and start talking
to former members of the Fantastic Four
it becomes interesting the reason why I
say this is because it's not something
that I initially expected to see right I
mean like you have Luke Cage for example
who joined the Fantastic Four in issue
number 168 and that ran for about three
issues or so you've got Medusa who
joined the Fantastic Four in issue 1 32
I think it was crystals been a part of a
team she-hulk was part of the Fantastic
Four she-hulk being here is basically
like look I was hired to keep these kids
out of jail because essentially Ben
Grimm wanted me to like the thing wanted
me to and so going in there like like
Ben's given essentially dropped all
charges because for the most part the
thing wasn't necessarily staged but at
this point he really kind of seems to
have like total detachment right like
maybe they'll come back maybe they won't
I don't know I don't care
I'm just moping around and being sad and
so he ends up telling the story to
what's basically the keratea caretaker
um and and it says hey look here's how
all these events unfolded right like
there's this secret story of the
Fantastic Four in this instance it's
basically just some chick some alien
chick who's kind of like not really
attached you for the spaceways but it's
familiar with the spaceways could the
result of this is that they're kind of
stuck out there you know and not really
sure where to go you know not really
sure would you know how to get back to
their own dimension
and so what ends up happening is this
chick basically says so this stone can
amplify the resonant frequency of a
voice in order to essentially provide
you a gateway provide you a portal back
to your dimension and what I need is
your best singer and of course Susan
storm speak they speak something she's
like well I'm the best thing over the
Fantastic Four
everybody else is like no not really
it's actually Johnny storm but it's kind
of cool because ultimately you know like
you like Johnny storm starts singing the
portal opens they end up traveling back
to the main to the main Marvel Universe
dimension and like you still won't stop
singing which is kind of funny but it's
one of these cool things because what
dance lots doing here is it's not just
the return of the Fantastic Four it's
moving them in a different director
moving in a forward direction the
Fantastic Four have largely been a
stagnant team which is to say they had
progression up until about the late
1960s to about 1968 when essentially
they said when Marvel Comics stopped
using definitive points in time and so
like ever since then the Fantastic Four
have just been a team that explores
different adventures and and charts to
space way as spaceways and multiverses
or I guess other other universes in the
multiverse is so on and so forth which
is fine but like Ben Grimm and Alicia
masters have been together for like
forty years so it's time to like move
things forward and so what Ben Grimm
does is go to the home of Alicia masters
and propose and it's a cool thing to see
because you know if you if you were if
you're not really a longtime fan of the
Fantastic Four this isn't really
relevant to you because in the grand
scheme of things it doesn't really
matter but when you're talking about
like you know people who have been
reading or a reading Fantastic Four for
like a long long time you know twenty
thirty years it makes sense it was kind
of one of those things where it's like
yeah this should have happened a long
time ago again Dan Slott is super good
at writing like characters writing like
how characters would respond in a given
situation when it comes to this whole
thing Johnny just kind of freaks out
right because like Ben's responses hey I
want you to be my best man and Johnny's
like no this is ridiculous no one should
be the best man except for Reed Richards
and that's why I say Dan Slott so good
at writing characters is because when it
comes to like the Fantastic Four
Reed is always the focal point like he's
always the central hub of the team when
you're talking about all these different
things it makes sense that like given
the friendship that Ben and Reed have
had because they've they've been friends
for so long since their college years it
makes sense it like it should be Reed
who's the the best man of Ben Grimm and
so finally after all of this Johnny kind
of has to accept the fact that it
doesn't seem like the Fantastic Four are
going to return to they're not going to
come back because if they were they
would have been here by now it's an
interesting moment because it's him
finally coming to grips with the reality
and at this point we switch over to the
Fantastic Four we switch over to Ed Reed
and Susan and again this is one of the
coolest moments it's a small little
thing that happens it's a conversation
between Reed and Susan she asked are you
sure this is going to work you know it
seems like it's an impossible thing to
do and
question is do you as my wife believe in
me and she says yes he says that's why I
can do the impossible because you
believe that I can and this is why I
love these things so much because dance
slots so good at writing people in
relationships and so what is up
happening is they kind of send out a
signal essentially shoot out a flare and
it's kind of like hey look we are alive
out here and we're coming home and so
it's so cool because the Fantastic Four
are finally making their return to
Marvel Comics but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoy this video make sure you drop
a like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]